este 8 de noviembre de los
estadounidenses están llamados a las
urnas para renovar completamente los 435
escaños de la cámara baja y elegir a un
tercio del senado
el presidente Joe biden teme perder la
frágil mayoría que tienen las dos
cámaras en la cámara de representantes
donde mejor Leo al partido demócrata
tiene una escasa mayoría de 8 escaños
mientras que en el senado para poder
hacer frente a los republicanos va a ir
en depende de los independientes y de la
vicepresidenta de la nación kamala
Harris que ejerce como presidenta de la
cámara alta desde hace varias décadas
George W Bush ha sido el único
presidente en salir victorioso en las
elecciones de mitad de término en el año
2002 Estos comicios son una evaluación
del período presidencial dos años luego
de ocupar la Casa Blanca Joe biden llega
debilitado por la guerra en Ucrania y
sus consecuencias económicas mientras
que los republicanos se muestran fuertes
culpando a biden de la reciente crisis
migratoria y de una inflación con
récords históricos que ronda el 10%.
Además del Congreso los ciudadanos
también elegirán gobernadores en 36 de
los 50 estados
así como jueces y funcionarios locales
temas importantes en la agenda política
y social de Estados Unidos también se
decidirán cinco estados refrendarán el
aborto luego de que la Corte Suprema
derogara el caso Rober versus wade Joe
ha tratado de abanderarse de la defensa
del aborto en campaña Y promete un
respaldo Federal si los demócratas
obtienen mayoría
vayan también promete regular el porte
de armas sin embargo lo que más preocupa
la electorado de la primera Economía del
mundo es la disminución del poder
adquisitivo un tema clave en la campaña
republicana